[Music]
gamer's the first set always hits the
best bro look at this I'm so on brain
feels good me get tied because today
we're watching 11 vs. 1 rating guides by
looks and personality another you belay
how can you be so shallow and rate
people by their looks
that's disgusting zero zero zero that's
what you get you believe I'm kidding
you're all beautiful on the inside let's
freakin do this also she's the one
rating huh okay well fine what a Karen
move huh isn't he can't believe this I'm
disgusted they would never do this with
girls oh wait they totally did okay all
right fine fine
a billion likes and I'll do another one
really excited but also really nervous
not like a number but we definitely like
judge I guess unbelievable I never judge
a person in my entire life this seems
like a horrible person in every single
way get it because I'm judging her
that's the joke alright
wait she's rating them right in front of
them that's just mean
oh my god his sex symbol man
self-proclaimed I wonder what he's gonna
get yes I'm excited they don't get to
hear their radios should I do it as well
no I would never do that
for ya
five six seven is eight even eight go
away or body type wise he's just not
someone I would approach what dude he's
a little chunky ain't nothing wrong with
that it could be your big chunga's I
hold some reddit moment come on come on
how can he be so shallow hello
oh look tall guy tall guy let's see what
they get hey this guy is very tall as
well as it seems he's attractive but
kind of giving me like frat boy vibes
okay frat boy vibes
he's a track damn that's a pretty good
compliment you look good he looks like
friendly but also like tough which I
kind of like eight with those thing in
this ear
no offense if you had those thing in
your no problem but no no eight from me
all right what is he gay what is it yet
he's not necessarily like exact type no
sexy bull gets a six unbelievable
wearing unmatched socks cringe the next
guy what a monster look at these tangles
what's wrong with people my chest thing
I've been untangling for years oh my god
zero because of the tangling for sure
for sure
Oh
or yeah you deserve a for he looks very
approachable but he's a little ah ah
what is gonna what is he gonna read him
that short I knew wait disgusting
ain't nothing being short and not that I
could relate but no problem next one oh
you have to be taller than three I'm
done with this I'm gonna play tap Titans
instead which I alright
he's so short
like his belt I feel like he takes care
of himself how do you see that by
looking on someone they all look the
same they all look like they take care
of themselves they're wearing the same
God I've got it what a rude why am I
getting so upset over this I'm defending
my own ow
it's all good I got you back you're a
ten you're a ten you're Silla for I hate
you oh you're six kidding I'm kidding it
looks like fun time I guess four damn
these are low ratings what any any
reason for that chief you want to care
to elaborate on that one bro
totally not well I see the headphones my
man you're a Sarah I'm sorry I didn't
like it but it was good lice is all so
now she gets to meet them she gets to
sit down and just your personalities
okay alright what does big chunga's gay
I'm Angela nice to meet you nice to meet
you I just want to say like you're
really pretty
thank you have you ever been to UM Eaton
Canyon no I haven't been
if I ever do get chance to take you out
there you know and I see you smiling I
think that'll be like the best part of
the hike eating Canyon he wants to go
eat with her I'm so confused
she's not into it
on paper like he sounded really cool but
I don't know I feel like just that
connection you look for like I didn't
really feel that Wow
oh she gets the right personality double
for bro you're done you're done
virgin for life god damn poor chunga bad
chunga's noises watch strange things
because he looks like he looks like one
of the characters from strange things
isn't he so I pulled up a picture you
know which one do you like
stranger things cuz I look like the guy
from strange things I don't like it
god dammit god dammit - man's gotta - oh
no no no no she was really hate stranger
things huh damn I never met anyone a
good day would be an arcade or bowling I
like bowling what's your favorite food
probably Italian Jew yellow bread I
could feel myself like smiling the whole
time and he likes brightest ate man's
got an 8 because man like bright women
is that only takes when I with my chick
I had to brag about yo-yo Championships
all my achievements man just comes and
says he likes brain and that's all a
dates they said all right now we know
now we know what's your credit score
yeah I mean you should know your credit
score what's your credit score well I'm
not trying to flex but it's like 7:20
damn you got a 6 for that that's kind of
funny though I got a lot of because he
overplayed on the last episode I
obviously made fun of him a lot but he's
funny I don't hate like it's weird how
people hate the characters from this
show it's just a silly show by a 6 for
sure absolutely
I take the untie in like a month that's
eight hours long
good luck I don't think I'm a bad person
putting that out there I'm like okay
person may be good try not to laugh
you got a seven for that what about Bobo
what's Bobo what are they talking that's
called Mary ballet on sod towel that's
pretty good you want to mark out what
they're off Friday is so good oh they're
really connecting nine man's got nine
I'm rooting for it
hell yeah hell yeah Richard Bryan
looking [ __ ]
he's in I'm actually working my money
the other day we made our jambalaya you
just say anything food related and
she'll write you hi apparently what the
hell is this
I like Brett hey nice to meet you hey
nice to meet you my name is Phil I like
bread we go
guess yo-yo is a bit outdated now huh
[ __ ] don't like yo-yos anymore cringe
I was born in the Philippines that's
cool
you should make our parents pad and do
like like some one of my same culture
seven huh did you go to like Coachella
same culture jambalaya
same thing I'm predicting that Rihanna
is gonna head by next year oh yeah that
is her before I'm predicting you're
gonna get a low rating oh wait you
already did
Rihanna's gonna headline in talks like
that people have other interests cringed
I did aerospace engineering math easy to
talk to everything sweet yeah yeah
all right kind of afraid to actually
actually I remember the headphones that
no no run
run don't make my mistake don't make my
mistake I'm joking I am so happy
besides the headphones everything was
perfect okay probably the personality
the personality guy look pretty but I
can't talk to you about anything it's
like how is that gonna go rich Brian won
he did eh
there's hope there result I just have a
lot of fun getting to know you I enjoy
talking to you as well so you just want
to keep getting to know each other a
little bit more I mean if you want to
he's pretty submit sure I mean I've seen
these sides probably more oh yeah
surprise for you but stand up nothing
changes Bo he's taller than you why are
you rated with 3 he's taller she rated
him low because she wasn't taller
I mean opposite of what I said well 1/2
of what office said what I said yeah
look it's way taller breath personality
pretty high you know usually like
looks-wise no but like personality wise
like I raised she's gonna die so that's
kind of cool ish you picked the
personality over look but at the same
time is she gonna have to tell him what
she rated him cuz that's gonna be
interesting usually when I pick people
now it's like out of social setting and
it's definitely all by looks because I
don't get to talk to all of them
it's definitely change my perspective a
little bit on like how I write better
you know I appreciate her bringing out
the person that has the highest
personality because I think that you can
grow to become physically attracted to
them if you and if your personalities
align very well I thought was gonna say
grow as a person and not be so kind
shallow but okay I guess that works too
sure oh it's all good I mean I was
standing next to pretty tall dudes
oh just stop just stop dude I'm not a
sex enough F in the chat this is so sad
thank you I'm hoping she didn't like
give me a zero all right thank goodness
damn cool early that's dope so happy
I don't know wait to see the video if
you have to choose between physical
that's interesting
I like that good episode Jubilees go sub
to them it's a great channel react to
your videos thank you if you enjoyed
this video hit like button subscribe
we're trying to beat Coco melanin
subscribers it's not a war or race or
any competition but we have to win you
understand
tambourine gets larger for every meal
subscribe not nearly big enough not
nearly get big enough we're
live-streaming lots of us right now if
you want to become a member that's epic
join the community and I'll see you guys
tomorrow
hey don't porn a also improv fists if I
didn't they see I can be cool or not
cringy yeah ok
you haven't played super simulator on
the beach good pack your bags and sit
down no one wants to see your face max
tan lines
anyway download tuber simulator for the
perfect beach body
you